man I I said this uh like a year or two
ago but man I I still don't like themed
cafes in Japan they're like
collaboration cafes because of the food
the food and drink is like a jerk it
looks good that's the thing is that I
hate the fact that we're turning like
food impractical we're like we're like
okay well we put a little uh I went to
the Square Enix one oh yeah and then
they made me a latte and I was like this
latter tastes really bad yeah yeah but
they put a slime on it so I guess now
it's worth nine dollars yeah and I'm
like what uh there's only been I've been
to so many themed cafes because Archie
loves going to them I know um because
she makes content out of it so it's
understandable but uh I think the only
good one where I would actually go back
for the food is the Kirby Cafe and I
know it's good because no no I know it's
good because the biggest Kirby facts
Cafe has the best food it does water
what a coincidence it legitimately does
and I know I'm not the only one who
thinks that because it was a temporary
thing at uh [ __ ] Tokyo Skytree but
now they maybe made it a permanent thing
so you know if a themed Cafe turns
permanent that that's how you know that
the food is good because if the food
sucks then people don't come back it's
like a novelty to it that's really
short-lived and once you've like
experienced all the food and you've
experienced that themed cafes like you
know style and everything and you've got
grabbed all the [ __ ] merch you can
because there's always a merch shop
attached to it as well then you're not
gonna go back it's I don't know because
to me it's like the food itself is is
the art yeah don't draw all over my
state don't reassemble the carrots to
look like a smiley face but I think
that's why I like the Kirby Cafe because
the Kirby Cafe they don't [ __ ] around
with the food they [ __ ] around with the
cutlery so like the plates are like
certainly [ __ ] like shaped in certain
ways or like the cups are shaped in
certain ways but the actual food itself
is normal once you once you put it on a
regular plate I don't know if I'm like a
scrooge or something just don't enjoy
fun or whatever but like I just don't
want people like making faces or [ __ ]
out with my food I don't want my food to
be like a toy I get I I I'm I'm exactly
the same way where if I go to a themed
something of like something I'm a fan of
then I don't want them to [ __ ] around
with the food
look look I'm I'm here for a good time
to enjoy the thing I like I'll buy them
give me like cool mud give me like cool
exclusive merch that I can buy in a
better way to get one with the show than
to digest the show I'll do like [ __ ]
typical examples when we went to the
Bucky exhibit right yeah I saw this
poster that was like oh just down the
block there is a the Bucky Cafe like a
Bucky themed Cafe and my friend and I
were like because you know I was like
hitting around you know lunch time like
early afternoon we were like all right
let's let's go check it out all right
let's go see the menu and I saw the menu
and I was like this is the laziest
attempt at a themed Cafe but one of them
was like retsukayo's Neapolitan pasta
and I'm like what the when does retsu
ever eat Napoleon pasta in [ __ ] Bucky
it's like they are really [ __ ]
stretching it they're like they're
really stretchy to make it on breathe
yeah it's Mickey Mouse's world famous
lasagna yeah
one of them was like you hugee Rose a
cappuccino and it's like it didn't even
have uterus face on it it was literally
just a cappuccino nine dollars
battery themed cafes are meant to in
Japan where they have a dish on the menu
that's just like you know [ __ ] uh
rin's special Curry from Fate Stay nine
and I'm just like when when did this
happen how is this on brand why did you
just addict you literally just added a
character to a random dish
I find it like insulting it's like
you're you're you're insulting my
intelligence yeah you're insulting my
fandom yeah yeah I like you think I'm
just gonna buy this because you put this
character on it I'll take two but
but like you like if you if you had put
the [ __ ] like Neapolitan pasta in
front of me I would have been like oh
it's just the rail in the Paul's
impossible like do you think that if if
they were like but it's retires no
problem then I'd be like whoa [ __ ]
sign me up then I'm gonna eat the [ __ ]
out of this like this is why like when
you go to like Wolfgang Puck's
restaurant he doesn't serve like [ __ ]
smiley faces on his stage you know I
mean like I just don't want I just don't
want that like I don't want it it's just
like the stage it's a really nice
restaurant yeah there's initials yeah
what the [ __ ] is this what is this is a
horse like we're branding it was it
running away like what's going on like
this is our state yeah like I I just
don't like that yeah to me it's like
it's such if a food has done well it
itself is so beautiful now pay for it
and it speaks more but you know just
have the decor of the cafe have
everything else be like just just make
it like everything else but the food
have cool Cutlery have a Cool vibe you
know have a have a cool aesthetic you
know make make it feel like you're right
if it's Kirby make it so that the toilet
Kirby and I can lift up his face yeah
and I can sit and [ __ ] I think that's
what I appreciated about the Kirby Cafe
was that they didn't [ __ ] around with
the food they [ __ ] around with the
cutlery which you can then buy at the
[ __ ] merch store right so I was like
oh cool this is like a thing I can use
in my kitchen and it's like kind of neat
and dope and it doesn't have to I don't
have to make a [ __ ] curb no I've come
to Japan at some point I'm sure there'll
be tons yeah please like Kobe Cafe is
great um but like it's always a bunch
yeah but like you know for like for me
especially if when it's like cafes
especially that are like paired with
like exhibits or whatever right it's
just like just just give me some good
merch didn't they have the pen pineapple
pen Cafe yeah did they actually yeah I
made a video on it yeah yeah you did
yeah I made the video was this oh when
was pen pineapple maybe like six years
ago six years ago and I think it was
like 2016. yeah they made uh they made a
pop-up of pen pineapple Apple pen I
think it was at Tokyo Skytree or Tokyo
Tower whichever one it was right uh but
yeah you go in and all of the menu items
spelled out ppap uh you know because
that was it yeah they didn't even have
any uh like pineapple or apple based
products and I'm like I feel like you
really missed the ball it's paprika
right it was like a pen pineapple Apple
pen burger and I'm like what does this
have to do with pineapple Apple pen with
zero pineapple yeah no pineapple in the
burger
I don't mind it if it's done well but
like even then it's like they couldn't
even put the effort to do that and it's
like oh the thing I felt the most sorry
about was the fact that like I looked at
there was like two like clerks who were
like standing behind the counter and
they looked so dead inside because pen
pineapple Apple phone is playing on
repeat in the store all day I was there
for like a couple of hours and I was
like by like minute 20 I was like I want
to get the [ __ ] out of here just like
just shove a pen in my ears just like
blur out the sound they look so dead
well that's that's kind of how I feel
like all of the truck drivers who drive
around like [ __ ] Harajuku or whatever
and they have to drive around promoting
these Idols or whatever
album yeah
we swear we've mentioned it there's
these trucks that drive around Japan
where they'll play music yeah really
loudly yeah or decorative trucks yeah
yeah
they're awful it's basically just like a
moving billboard basically yeah yeah
basically weird in Japan you can't make
noise in your own apartment but anyone
can make as much noise as they want on
the street it's really weird yeah right
someone can come back
potatoes and uh intrude our like streams
yeah running for government just scream
in public yeah it's just like what what
year are we in where you don't don't you
have like social media you could promote
uh no but no I'm sure you're really
connected with the Youth of today by
driving around a truck what do they
expect for like everyone to come out of
their houses it's like guys honey wake
up it's up for new politicians in town I
mean even if it's old older people right
well they're gonna get up to go outside
to listen to you drive by oh maybe
that's why they're loud otherwise
they're not gonna like hear it right so
they just like broadcast they broke
foreign
people have to try and go towards the
older generation yeah so all the
techniques they use seem like archaic as
[ __ ] yeah it's the only way they can get
elected because if you're not in
someone's letterbox they're not they're
not getting into it isn't it weird isn't
it like they just the whole political
system is just catered what I just don't
understand though is like yeah I'm sure
they're like you know being loud as [ __ ]
right on the street so that again as you
were saying like it can reach the old
people's ears right yeah there's a lot
of people yeah as old age comes
naturally you become hard of hearing and
yet these same old people can hear like
the tiniest Creek from upstairs and be
like oh my God that's too [ __ ] loud
how dare they walk so loud in my
apartment meanwhile I'm having a really
hard time hearing this [ __ ]
politician on 17 megaphones just drive
past my house you know I need them turn
up a little bit louder
well well I don't know what like are
there any laws around like how much
noise you can make in Japan the past 10.
because it's something like that I don't
know like I don't know I feel I feel
half the time like people just don't
follow those laws yeah and there's like
always exceptions to the rule like you
know you could have like a bunch of like
like how come you know all these like
loud ass bikes that like drive through
like neighborhoods and you know not be
[ __ ] called on by the cops